behind me is a footprint of a twin tower
and this is my neighborhood i feel
incredibly lucky to live here it's
resilient it's beautiful when you live
down here and you work down here you end
up spending a lot of time thinking about
what happened here on september 11. new
york city is in shock and america is
under siege and now that it's been one
year since the taliban took control of
afghanistan people around the world are
thinking about it too with fresh signs
and reports that the taliban is once
again giving al qaeda safe haven in
afghanistan i went into the office to
talk to my colleague a former state
department official a former cia officer
and a terrorism analyst to talk about
whether we're seeing a resurgence of al
qaeda in afghanistan and what it would
mean for the world
these experts say that to understand
what's happening now you have to
understand the taliban's long history
with al qaeda
the terrorist organization behind
attacks that have killed thousands of
people around the world
when osama bin laden and his associates
were looking for a home for al qaeda in
the 90s they found refuge in taliban
controlled afghanistan
as a result al qaeda leaders bin laden
and dawahiri after him pledged loyalty
bayak is what they called it to the emir
the taliban afghanistan became a base
from which the group could communicate
organize train and plot
after bin laden masterminded the
september 11th attacks in 2001 the
taliban refused to give him up it was a
decision that brought the organizations
even closer together when the u.s
launched its invasion to root out both
that relationship you know it is a bond
that has um
been forged in fire it is about often a
bond of blood
during the insurgency members of al
qaeda and the taliban often intermarried
and analysts and officials say al-qaeda
gave the taliban vital support teaching
fighters how to use truck bombs suicide
vests and roadside explosives against
the west
the 20-year conflict america's longest
war began to wind down after the trump
administration struck a deal to withdraw
troops in exchange for taliban promises
on terrorism
very importantly the u.s taliban
agreement entails a promise from the
taliban that terrorists can never again
operate
from afghan soil but the taliban didn't
say anything about breaking with al
qaeda it said nothing about them
actually cutting ties the deal was so
vaguely worded because the u.s was in
such a rash to get it done and the
taliban had the upper hand because they
knew the u.s was in a rush
a year later the taliban capitalized on
a chaotic withdrawal by the biden
administration sweeping across the
country to seize provincial capitals and
ultimately kabul in a matter of days we
begin with afghanistan and the dramatic
fall of the capital scores of taliban
fighters and just behind us the u.s
embassy compound we're being just
surrounded by dozens and dozens of
people who are desperate to leave
and according to the united nations al
qaeda aided and advised the taliban as
it did that and when the taliban formed
a new government al-qaeda allies were
appointed to senior roles
the un also says that al qaeda is
enjoying greater freedom under the new
regime and earlier this year officials
say ayman al-zawahiri the leader of al
qaeda himself moved to the heart of
afghanistan's capital where he was
ultimately taken out by a u.s drone
strike i authorized a precision strike
that would remove him from the
battlefield once and for all u.s
officials say he was living in a safe
house next door to a home owned by a
taliban official but not just any
taliban official the powerful minister
of interior who happens to be a
long-time al-qaeda ally the fact that a
safe house associated with this movement
and this man was being used by the
leader of al-qaeda is highly significant
it's not an accident this sort of
protection only happens if al qaeda is
getting buy-in for that from the highest
levels of the taliban government
while it's not clear if zawahiri himself
was plotting attacks he served as a
figurehead to unite al-qaeda affiliates
worldwide and in recent months he was
filming videos to thousands of al qaeda
supporters
in a statement the taliban said there is
no threat to any country including
america from the soil of afghanistan it
vowed to investigate the drone strike
experts say that freedom to communicate
and operate is crucial for terrorist
groups terrorist groups thrive in safe
havens like al qaeda did in afghanistan
before 9 11. it gives them the space to
operate freely it gives them a sanctuary
to plan attacks to raise money to train
operatives to move fighters in and out
to war zones or other target zones so
given that is it fair to assume that a
sanctuary anywhere makes these
organizations stronger everywhere
certainly in the sense that they do
interact that these affiliates do try to
support one another over the years al
qaeda has found support in places like
syria yemen west africa and somalia and
that has allowed the organization to
persist as a dangerous and decentralized
network those places could potentially
be used by al qaeda to try to launch
attacks against the west since a u.n
report suggests that the group is being
careful not to embarrass the taliban by
launching attacks from afghanistan this
is the real danger of afghanistan it
doesn't make the danger in somalia or
mali or yemen or syria or you know name
your country where al qaeda has risen
since 9 11. it doesn't diminish the
threat there i would argue it makes this
threat all the more um all the greater
and it makes and afghanistan arms burns
as a nexus to this threat the us isn't
the only country that has been rocked by
terrorism to learn more about how
terrorist activity in africa has led
some there to welcome russian
mercenaries check out this video thanks
for watching i'll see you again soon